hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and on this
podcast we'll often talk about
scientific advances what we learn about
the universe but sometimes we also talk
about philosophical questions of right
and wrong the morality and the ethics of
how we should lead our lives and these
domains of science and ethics bump into
each other they're not separate
sometimes we're forced or nudged toward
asking ethical questions about
scientific and technological advances
we've learned something about the
universe we've developed the ability to
do something with our scientific
knowledge but should we do that thing
should it be legal to do that thing and
these are not just dorm room philosophy
questions either the government often
has to make decisions about what should
and should not be legal when science
introduces new possibilities into our
lives so today we welcome an
honest-to-goodness
law professor on to the podcast for the
first time and we'll be talking about a
wide range of questions dealing with
these bio ethical and legal issues all
Toshiro
is a professor of law and bioethics at
the University of Wisconsin at Madison
and she's been active on both the
scholarship and policy sides of the
equation she served as a bioethics
adviser on the Obama administration
transition team when Obama became
president and she's also worked as a
senior policy advisor at the Food and
Drug Administration when she's not in
that kind of policy role she's a
professor writing articles in various
journals and she's written extensively
on things like stem-cell research gene
editing abortion religious exemptions to
providing medical care should you be
able to you know not provide a certain
medical service if your religious belief
says it's not right cloning organ
donation and many many more she's
extremely broad thinker in these issues
and we're gonna talk about them we're
gonna go through a whole list of
interesting issues at the intersection
of biology ethics and the government the
legal side of things and we're going to
also discuss what kind of comprehensive
philosophical framework might allow us
to address these questions in a
systematic way so let's go
[Music]
alta Chereau welcome to the mindscape
podcast pleased to be here now your
official self designation is as a bio
ethicist is that accurate yes and no I
am a professor of law and I work in the
field of bioethics I'm not sure anybody
knows how to define a bioethicists that
was one of the money questions I was
gonna ask so see your lawyer while a law
professor yes the bioethics is the field
of law that you specialize in that's
right and how would you try to define
bioethics he's starting with one of the
hardest questions easiest so really its
origins in recent history lie in the
1960s and 70s in two converging areas of
interest one had to do with population
growth and environmental conservation
and in fact the phrase bioethics was
actually coined in the context a
sustainable population growth you may
remember from the 1960s the zero
population growth movement and the
concerns of Malthusian future of
overpopulation inevitably destroying the
planet and so the phrase was actually
developed to discuss those dilemmas
about obligations to the future and at
the same time in the 1960s and 70s we
were seeing real advances in clinical
medicine and we were beginning to see
theologians particularly talking a lot
about what should or should not be part
of the medical toolkit particularly
things like genetic screening which had
implications for how much control we
take over our personal reproduction so
genetic screening in the sense of
checking someone's DNA as a baby carrier
screening carrier screening through
family pedigrees right then in the 1970s
amniocentesis where you would test the
amniotic fluid and look for chromosomal
defects and these things created a
situation where people had to make
choices about whether to have children
or whether to keep that particular
pregnancy whereas in previous
generations this was up to luck fate God
however you understood these things and
so you saw these two things begin to
converge about this notion of the
ethical obligations that we should
accept on behalf of others and also for
what is considered to be a good life and
by the 1970s late 1970s we began to see
the theologians the secular philosophers
the physicians and later the lawyers
because we push ourselves in everywhere
beginning to have conferences and
develop sets of principles over things
like how we should govern research with
human beings and how much respect
individuals are entitled to and that's
really where the field kind of begins I
would say to define a bioethicists is to
define somebody who is trying to grapple
with those questions but today they
might be sociologists or anthropologists
it could be empiricists who are looking
at the patterns of behavior or could be
theorists who are looking for a theory
about why you should or should not do a
particular thing I mean it's obvious
that what we can do today biologically
in terms of reproduction and so forth
there are scary new prospects
interesting promising new prospects out
there so the questions are changing very
rapidly but I still guess I'm a little
bit surprised that the field of
bioethics was not a thing before the
1960s I mean we had some issues
especially on the legal side right
forever
so it was it called something else or
were there no specialist than that I
think that the patterns before were
different and I think it's because with
the exception perhaps of understanding
the role of bacteria and disease and the
development of antibiotics medicine in
particular it was fairly powerless if
you look back at what medicine consisted
of a lot of it was really public health
brought down to the individual level eat
right and cetera and so even these older
theories about the different humors in
the body the wet the dry the hot the
cold if you looked at it really closely
often it wound up being eat a balanced
diet right what I mean some of it was
somebody was bad and you know cutting
people open and draining their blood bad
cocaine yeah yes right and
led in the makeup there were there was
some very big mistakes but in many ways
medicine was fairly impotent and then
suddenly with the advent particularly of
antibiotics it became powerful and power
is the point because with each
successive decade in the 20th century we
have gained more power over our own
physical bodies over our physical fate
and over
therefore the fate of our offspring both
knowledge and technology and technical
manipulation has advanced incredibly
fast now if you've ever gone to try and
pick a cell phone plan right I have I
think most people have had the same
experience which is I'm so confused by
the range of choices each one with a
different set of pros and cons so I
can't even like match them across some
kind of Excel spreadsheet that I wind up
not doing anything and I stick with
whatever I've got because it's good
enough right
with power comes choice and choices are
difficult figuring out first which
choice to make and why or should you
even have the choice if you get to the
point where you almost are sorry you
have the choice and that's the reason
why the power over our bodies and over
our futures created this kind of crisis
that led to an enormous global
conversation around what we now call
bioethics because every one of these new
powers demanded us to ask should we even
have the power to choose and if we are
going to choose which one should we
choose these are questions we never had
to ask before and it's very obvious that
the government would want to jump in and
the lawyers with them right it's it's is
the government very reflective about
these things about you know is there an
ongoing debate about whether the
government should even be involved in
what you might call a typical bio
ethical question this is really a matter
of almost political philosophy rather
than moral philosophy which is what most
people think about in the area of
bioethics and so you get two very
different answers very quickly because
different countries are based on
different political philosophies so
there was something back in the 1970s
and I believe it was from Newsweek I
have tried to Kath
tried to find it again I can't that
really captured the different kinds of
political philosophies around the world
and it went in the United States
everything is allowed until it's
prohibited Thursday that's fair yes in
East Germany everything is prohibited
until it's allowed and that was a very
stark way of having the contrast of
course they continued by saying in
Russia everything is prohibited
especially if it's allowed and in Italy
everything's allowed especially if it's
prohibited right right there was some
truth to those two so it did capture in
a weird way very well these very
distinct political cultures that drives
government action more than the actual
question take take human cloning which
became an issue in 1998 with dolly the
cloned sheep there was a tremendous
interest in the media there was the
unfortunate revelation of how poor our
education system is with regard to
biology because people continue to
imagine that cloning meant xeroxing
yourself and having an adult he's
identical to you I know do everything I
do right and there was the
misunderstanding that you could clone
personality as opposed to body type so
asked whom they would not want to clone
they'd say Saddam Hussein who was the
dictator of choice at the time and whom
would you want to clone and they would
say mother Teresa as if you were gonna
get a selfless nun as opposed to
somebody who was prone to scoliosis in
her old age right right so with cloning
you might think that there would be a
kind of common analysis that would lead
to the same conclusion about whether it
should be permitted or not by the
government is it the role of the
government to make the choice and what
choice should it make in fact that's not
at all what happened in fact what
happened is that with regard to cloning
we saw again the same reflection of
governmental approaches so in many
European countries where there is much
more of a comprehensive governmental
regulation and where the existence of a
public health care scheme means that you
can regulate Verte simply by saying we
will err will not offer certain services
you had a government that could actually
intervene and say this is a choice right
I mean the government did everything so
if something's gonna be done the
government's gonna be involved they're
democracies but the government had that
power whereas in the United States
instead of having general prohibition we
had a general absence of law there were
a handful of states that passed statutes
to criminalize clownin often over broad
because they criminalized even basic lab
research at the same time used to give a
talk called from stem cells to jail
cells about the scientists in these
states but at the federal level the
Congress talked about it there was some
you know murmurings nothing ever
happened and it's partly because we
don't have the easy Avenue in to
regulate so that's number one we can't
do it through just spending decisions
and second we have a constitution that
lays out individual rights against
government action in particular the
government may not abridge my right to
free speech or to assembly and we also
have this notion of a right to make
certain kinds of procreative decisions
free of government at least free of
government prohibitions not free of
government regulation and that creates a
counterweight to government action that
didn't exist in many of these European
countries so we wound up with different
policies that didn't reflect our views
about cloning everybody might have
thought it's a terrible idea or a good
idea it doesn't matter what it reflected
was the power of the government and
already it's we're into not only
political philosophy but constitutional
law in the sense that nowhere in the
Constitution does it talk about
reproductive rights or rights to have
sex in certain ways and so forth but
there's the idea that there's this
implied set of rights given by the Bill
of Rights you know not necessarily that
it numerated everything that we have but
it gives you the impression that the
government should keep his hands off of
certain things and this becomes welcome
tennis once you actually get into the
courts you know one fairly non
contentious area of constitutionally
protected rights is the right to marry
now we're talking just about hundred
sexuals right but No
there's nowhere in the Constitution that
says you have a right to marry and yet
it became the basis for striking down
the laws in Virginia that criminalized
marriage between people who are deemed
white and people who are deemed black
right this is the case of loving versus
Virginia one of the best name cases ever
I was a great one yeah great name so is
the right to marry the right to marry
and go now where did the where did the
court get it because the courts over the
years have come to recognize that at the
time the Constitution was written there
were two things that were in mind number
one something seems so obvious you
didn't have to say him like getting
married yeah should be able to get Mary
gets married and it goes along with his
philosophy that in the United States if
there's not a specific rule against it
right then you're allowed to do it but
but to have something as a
constitutionally protected right is a
little different than that because it
means that you're protected more
rigorously you know most this is
aggression but we'll get back to the con
law most of our liberties are ordinary
liberties my freedom to drive is an
ordinary Liberty and the government can
regulate that or even prohibit many of
these things so long as they have a
rational basis for it but when you have
something that is specifically
guaranteed in the Constitution whether
in the Bill of Rights or in one of these
pronouncements from the court as a
fundamental right then the government
can't stop you from doing it unless it
can show first of all a compelling need
not just a rational basis a compelling
need that cannot be answered by anything
that is less onerous so that is a very
very strict standard that is applied so
with the right to marry it raised it
from being a state that says well we
have a rational basis that intermarriage
is disruptive to the social order and it
puts the kids at a disadvantage might
have passed muster but if it's a
fundamental right then now the state has
to show that there's a compelling need
to stop these people from marrying and
that there's a disruption to society
that can't be handled any other way and
they couldn't meet that kind of balance
now that right to marries No
we're in the constitution partly because
at the Argent's nobody thought you had
to say it the second part of it is if
you look at what's in the original Bill
of Rights these are things that the
English actually were trying to stop
like assembly and speech or things that
they were doing like quartering soldiers
in our homes so of course this is what
was on their minds and the right to have
sex wasn't on their minds right so they
never can contemplate it that I would
need to be regulated at Langley actually
it was heavily regulated but by the
churches all right and it was regulated
at the state level not at the federal
level because each state tended to have
a different religious makeup but the
point simply is that over the years the
courts have recognized that the
Constitution is not a complete document
it's a starting point and they have
tried to fill in the gaps over time and
one of those gaps was the right to
privacy right where privacies of variety
of things that are not just about being
able to keep information to yourself but
also about being able to have a sphere
of action that is free from government
intrusion and a sphere of personal
interrelating of personal relationships
that is free of government introduced
and on that basis we got things like the
decision that Connecticut is not allowed
to criminalize the sale and use of
contraceptives for married couples
because the marital relationship is an
intimate one that should be beyond the
government's intrusion and then it moved
beyond that to a right to privacy about
the control of your own body when single
women were now protected by a
fundamental right to have access to
contraception so the government couldn't
criminalize it for single women no
longer it's a it's no longer about
marital intimacy now it's about
controlling your body and we really do
see that playing out through the Roe
versus Wade decision about controlling
my body during pregnancy and now we see
the extension of those things in other
areas like the right to marry being
extended beyond the heterosexual couples
and I think this is just a crucial point
in terms of understanding how the legal
system works here in the United States
that the courts do have this idea that
there really are rights that can be used
to strike down
even though these rights were not
explicitly written into the Bill of
Rights or the Constitution that there
that there is this feeling that we
should err on the side of letting people
do things even if those are not
delineated item by item I think that's
now become a matter of contention
interestingly enough right because there
there grew up starting with the
Federalist Society a couple of decades
ago this kind of movement within legal
thinking that the notion of a living
Constitution in which courts over time
are constantly trying to fill in these
these gaps is one that doesn't have any
limits that you have no control over
what the courts will do and therefore we
need to put the brakes on the courts and
here's where we can here's the way we'll
do it we'll say they're only allowed to
use things that were actually written
down in 1789 right so originalism
roughly speaking right now I have to say
that many of these people who call
themselves originalist including Justice
Antonin Scalia one of the most famous
ones failed completely to be originalist
when it led to an outcome they didn't
like so there was a lot of inconsistent
application but nonetheless that was the
that was the kind of clarion call well
and it sounds reasonable when you put it
that way right like we we need to
protect against the expansion can being
completely unchecked of the powers of
the courts to do whatever they want and
the powers of the Congress so in the
1930s when the debate was about a
related set of concerns called
substantive due process again not about
whether the procedure you use is fair
but about whether this is an area the
government should be mixed into it all
we had the Congress passing laws on for
example worker wages and health
protections which were struck down by
the courts as being beyond the purview
of the government right and so this led
to a crisis again about how do we reign
in the courts from in this case
undermining congressional enactments so
you know from different eras you get
this kind of see-sawing because it is a
country with a kind of tripod of key
institutions that are all checking one
another so it's natural that they go
through
a wobble right and you mentioned the
right to privacy and how this gets
implemented and obviously one big area
of clashing is between individual
conscience --is especially as they
reflect religious beliefs versus the
demands of the state to do one thing or
another there's many different areas in
which these clashes happen do you have a
general theory of how we should
adjudicate it when the personal
religious beliefs of a citizen ask that
citizen or demand that that citizen do
something of the government is not happy
with I do but it's not uncontested right
there are people that I wouldn't exist
agree completely I think there's two
levels on which you address this one is
the very abstract level of what is the
role of religion in the public life and
the shared public life of people in
United States
that's about whether or not I should see
the public square metaphorically
speaking is one where everybody
expresses their religious views even if
it adversely affects somebody else my
religious view says that black people
and white people shouldn't marry and so
I don't want to give an interracial
couple housing in my building so the
word express their religious views
there's a lot of kinds of expression not
talking that's right or wearing a symbol
there is also the because the argument
there would be I'm living my beliefs by
by rejecting them for housing because if
I let them live in my apartment building
I'm essentially blessing their Union
right or even tolerating their union is
considered to be a violation of my
beliefs that's so that one view is that
this cacophony of voices in the public
square operates to the benefit of us all
because we all get to do what we want
even if it hurts somebody else and we
all have to figure out how to protect
ourselves against somebody else the
completely conflicting view is that the
public square should be one that is
absolutely a vacuum when it comes to
religion and you want to express your
religion fine go do it in your own
living room go do it in your own church
mosque synagogue
temple whatever but when you come into
the public square you must abide by a
set of rules that are going to be the
same for everybody and nobody's allowed
to feel like they are sudden how an
oddity or a minority or anything like
that
that's one set of competing theories but
how to deal with this because it's a
fundamental problem more narrowly in
bioethics we have seen it really come to
the fore when it comes to medical
professionals and certain medical
procedures in particular contraception
and abortion right to a somewhat lesser
extent some of the issues around how it
is that we help people die peacefully
okay yeah that's an important aim and
here I think that we shouldn't be
looking at it as a contest between
religious expression and secular
equality I don't think that's the right
way to look at it I think we need to ask
about power dynamics and what it means
to be a professional because as a
physician or as a pharmacist you
basically are taking an oath to serve
your patient and you have more power
than the patient in fact for doctors and
pharmacists there's a monopoly power I'm
not a physician I'm not allowed to
prescribe contraception or perform an
abortion only a physician can do it and
because it's a closed community the
community has an obligation to make all
legal services available it otherwise we
would have the public utilities the
electric company could say we're not
going to provide electricity to Planned
Parenthood or to the KKK headquarters
and you don't want that they just give
that electricity right right and so I
would say we need to look at power
dynamics so I you know in the area of
conscience I would find it more
defensible if somebody who's a checkout
clerk at a supermarket said I am a
devoted vegetarian and vegan I don't
believe in the use of animals for foods
so I'm simply not going to ring up any
animal products right and I can't be
fired from my job I don't want to be
fine that's the that's the point with
the physicians too they don't want to be
fired they don't want to be denied
promotion they don't want to be
vulnerable to malpractice suits and here
the clerk doesn't want to be fired and I
actually think that's more defensible
because it's much easier for somebody to
go to the other line or for the company
to make sure that they've actually hired
a lot of people most of whom will do
animal products and there's really not
the same kind of power differential that
there is between the
during patience so you think that
there's a social interest in these cases
where we we as a society have given so
much power to certain groups of people
part of the contract is okay then you
have to do the things that society wants
you to do that's exactly right and if
you really don't want to take on those
obligations you should look for a
different kind of vocation where you
don't find yourself in this kind of a
conflict in other words should your
religious restrictions that create moral
crises for you be your problem right or
should they be everybody else's problem
right because we do want on the other
hand to let people have freedom of
expression in these sort of narrow sense
of expression you know worship in
whatever way they want it gets into not
just professionals like doctors or
pharmacists but families right parents
raising children who don't want to give
certain kinds of medical care to their
kids and you might think that doctors
should be obligated to do the
appropriate procedures and yet also
believe that parents shouldn't be
obligated to have those procedures done
to their kids so you've now touched on
two more topics that are central to the
way we discuss things in bioethics
you've you've touched on the notion of
individual autonomy and capacity to give
consent very closely linked in the case
you're describing of parents and medical
care we would in bioethics probably find
ourselves talking about the parents
having the right as autonomous competent
individuals to make decisions about
their own health care or lack thereof
and that when their children come of age
their children would have the same
privilege but that while the children
are young and therefore really not able
to make the decisions for themselves now
the question is do parents have
unlimited discretion to make decisions
for their children or is there some
point where we stop and we say you know
now it's the society that makes the
decision and of course we take children
away from abusive parents right and we
don't argue that parents have a right as
autonomous beings to beat their children
now with people who engage in things
like faith healing there's no evil
motive like there is with
your child but the result can be the
same which is that the child is gravely
injured or dies and that is the point at
which the state steps in so most places
happen have some kind of statute that
tries to lay out a border line where the
parental decisions are now putting the
child at high risk of having permanent
or serious injury or could lead to death
at which point the state takes over yeah
I think this this gets right into I
think if we're fuzzy sometimes we fool
ourselves about the relationship between
morality and religion and law right like
we we tell ourselves well you can have
your personal religious beliefs but
there is the law that everyone obeys in
the country and they should be able to
get along but of course we use our
personal notions of morality to guide
what laws we think there should be right
like murder is bad that feeds into
passing a law that murdering is bad and
that goes back to complete the cycle
into the fundamental nature of living in
a pluralist society right like we again
we pretend that we can all get along
even though our fundamental values might
be very very different and it seems
necessary to me that the ability to obey
your own personal fundamental values can
only go so far if you do live in a part
in a pluralistic society this you're
absolutely right is one of the great
challenges of a country that talks about
being a melting pot in fact I think it's
more like a stew now a melting pot
suggest that everybody winds up the same
right that is not what is happening as
somebody who grew up in New York in an
intensely ethnic borough with a little
bit of this and a little bit of that I
can tell you that it was a stew the
Italians the Irish the Eastern European
Jews the South Asian Indians every one
of those households had a distinctly
different culture and yet when we all
played together in the street there did
there was a kind of common soup that all
these little chunks of culture were
sitting in and flavored all of them I
mean honest goodness I grew up not being
completely sure whether lasagna was a
Jewish food or not and that's because of
the world that I lived in
so if you're gonna live in a stew you
have to acknowledge there are gonna be
these differences right right so how do
you decide what's gonna be the common
soup the common flavoring that tinges
everything you know there are
philosophers like John Rawls with whom I
understand you had a chance to to study
who worked really hard to try and
articulate some methodology by which we
could arrive at rules for law or
governing or common morality and a key
thing that he talked about was the idea
of so-called publicly accessible
reasoning that is you may conclude that
murder is wrong because you are a
devotee of the Ten Commandments and the
Ten Commandments say thou shalt not kill
I may come from a totally different
culture I don't look to the Ten
Commandments but I have a culture that
lives by a golden rule I don't want to
be murdered therefore it's wrong for me
to murder therefore I conclude murder is
wrong and we now converge on a common
moral rule in even a legal rule that
murder is wrong because we can get there
through some common sets of reasoning
now if we're if where you're coming from
is one where there's no way for you to
explain it except by reference to your
particular religion
there's no non faith-based argument at
all that could work for somebody who
doesn't share your faith then we have a
problem and that would not comfortably
fit in our laws because it really is a
rule that only makes sense to a subset
of the population well that's
interesting because I think that where
you ended up was slightly different than
where I thought you were going I thought
what you were gonna say was that it kind
of doesn't matter what your
justification is if you're the practical
implementation of that justification
agrees from lots of different people ah
fair enough and I did I kind of slid
there and I think that both of those are
true actually if we can both come up
with the same solution from different
premises that works if you can step back
from your let's say religious premise
that this is ordained by a deity and yet
you can explain to me
who doesn't share your view about that
deity why it is nonetheless a bad thing
and persuade me then that would be the
publicly-accessible reasoning the
reasoning that all people could somehow
get on board with without having to
accept where you're coming from in terms
of religious faith and both of those
things would lead to laws that are going
to be manageable across the population
so that sounds great
to me personally now there will always
be exceptions right I mean we can
imagine families where in their view
they have this religion thing figured
out they know what God says and God says
certain specific things and the fact
that a child might not get a certain
medicine and therefore will die is
ultimately a good thing because the
child would go to heaven as opposed to
if we did give them medicine then they
would not go to heaven and that's that
sounds like an irreconcilable difference
with the public demand I think there are
those moments I do think there are those
moments yes I think we accommodate them
so long as it is an autonomous rational
competent adult who's making the
decision for him or herself where we
change the rules is not on where you're
irreconcilable difference affects you
and you alone it's where it affects
somebody else who in no way is in a
position to have welcomed this kind of
decision for themselves and that's why
we make the distinction in that so the
flip side of that at the end of life
would lead you to say that people should
be able to decide what their end of life
is I mean we're very touchy right now
right we're you know I've talked about
this on other podcasts
we're undergoing this transition when
it's becoming more common to have Death
with Dignity laws or something like that
where people don't need to go through
all the possible medical procedures to
keep themselves alive or even can
essentially commit suicide can ascend
essentially in their own lives and this
is not something that I think a lot of
people are yet happy with but it would
go in the direction of that give the
person that grown-up autonomy over their
own decision and indeed if you look at
going back to the Supreme Court you look
at the Supreme Court decisions you see
that the decisions around things like
contraception and abortion included
language about
liberté that would comfortably encompass
the right of the individual to be free
of a state law that criminalizes the
effort to take a drug that's going to
allow you to die comfortably instead of
having to starve yourself to death or go
for go comforting medical procedures now
we have buried in our common law which
is not constitutional it's the kind of
ordinary daily law that we have going
all the way back to England and is
handled through things like civil
litigation like torts great we have
there this notion of bodily autonomy
that's why if I touch you in a way that
is harmful or offensive without your
permission it's a battery and I have to
pay you damages if you sue me and on
that basis people have long been
entitled since the 1970s has been clear
to refuse medical treatments even
medical treatments that are needed to
keep them alive the Death with Dignity
argument was about whether that also
should include not just the right to
reject a physical intrusion but to take
upon yourself something that will help
you die more peacefully and that's
actually something active and that's
where the debate about Liberty really
went and I've always found it intriguing
that the court has not really faced it
the way they could and really should
because if we're gonna talk about a
Liberty that encompasses your your
psychological and emotional state you're
talking about things like contraception
for men their bodies are not implicated
they're not the ones going to get
pregnant so if you think there's a right
for men to be able to obtain
contraception without the state throwing
them in jail you're saying that right
having men have a right to control their
futures in this very important way that
would suggest the same thing would be
true at the end of life but if I may all
of these things go back to the earlier
point about power because whether it's
modes of conception with gamete donation
and surrogate mothers and IVF or it's
death with dignity and use of drugs part
of the argument simply has been whether
human beings ought to have any control
over these very fundamental moments in
the human existence or whether that
ought to be somehow beyond our control
and in the hands of and fill in how you
think of it your deity fate nature
something else right so it sounds like
the distinction that you're trying to
emphasize here is that we can allow for
autonomy of persons for their own
well-being but as soon as they are put
in a position of power over others they
have to obey the rules and you'll notice
by the way that in the public health
world we are constantly running up
against the libertarian objection to
public health law so if it's about me
having to not pollute the water that you
drink we understand that but if it's
about why I can't drink raw milk which
has a objectively higher risk of giving
me a really ugly condition which will
have me vomiting and with diarrhea for
days ah any laws that prohibit the sale
of that to me are viewed as nanny state
right because they are impinging on my
autonomy right so we see the same debate
playing out over and over and over in
the United States I'm kind of on board
with the idea that if someone really
wants to poison themselves by drinking
raw milk they should be able to do that
and actually the way I said it is a
little bit misleading because there is
no law that says you can't drink we're
on milk the laws are about prohibiting
the sale of it right but that's kind of
that's a little different that's about
whether we can regulate the economy
right and it's exactly why in most
states where there is some kind of
prohibition on the sale of raw milk
there's also an exception for the
farmers on family for guests on the farm
there are people who then bought shares
of a farm so that they could be
considered the farmer as well in order
to be able to have access but it is
about trying to make sure that you don't
allow a profit to be made off of the
distribution of a product that is
manifestly
high risk you must not just this week in
California there was a controversy about
cancer warnings on coffee
yes you know California loves putting
warnings on things and saying they're
gonna kill you and I think that the
breaking point was when it seemed as if
you would have to put a warning on
coffee that you got at Starbucks saying
this might give you cancer and finally
well said no no this is going too far I
mean it's already very clear to anyone
who lives in California that there's a
sign in every establishment saying
things you're going to give you cancer
and we ignore the sign it becomes
useless it becomes counterproductive
well yes so there's certainly the over
warning problem and although all the
warnings then become a mush there's a
second problem though and that is the
failure to make a distinction between
hazard and risk many substances are a
hazard coffee this week also the news
glyphosate which is a weed killer that's
used in in Roundup Ready crops is
present in Cheerios and so the headlines
were all about how your children are
being poisoned in their Cheerios but in
fact linked Oreos are known to be
unhealthy for others but a hazard is
something that has the capacity to cause
some kind of harm but the risk is the
hazard and the probabilities and so you
have to ask what is the exposure that is
needed and in the case of coffee and
frankly in the case of glyphosate as
well the exposure has to be I don't know
what the number is many many many many
many orders of magnitude greater than
anybody consumes in order to actually
have this possible effect remember this
is only probabilistic that it might in
some percentage of situations causing
cancer so this is part of the problem of
the over warning if you only talk about
the fact that something is capable of
causing cancer well you know most of the
foods we eat would wind up on that list
because if consumed in sufficiently
enormous amounts you could distort the
human body in ways that then in turn
will cause some failure of your immune
system or something that eventually that
leads to cancer so California and and
many of the other groups that want
warnings for anything that ever showed
that it could show it could cause cancer
and grossly overfed caged rats me to
actually add in some mathematics exactly
no you're speaking our language here a
whole theme of my various podcast
episodes is calculating probabilities
updating them being good Bayesian
evaluating things rationally and trying
to make decisions and it's not very
automatic right the human brain doesn't
work that
we see oh there's something that could
be cancerous in here but therefore let's
not eat it and that actually it takes me
back to what I wanted to pick up a
previous threat we talked about how
religious beliefs could lead people to
object to certain governmental mandates
but isn't a lot of that really coming
down to just squeak eNOS isn't a lot of
what drives people to object to very
cutting edge bio procedures whether it's
cloning or stem cell research or
whatever just the fact that doesn't seem
natural to us it seems somehow
icky and therefore let's err on the side
of not doing it am i oversimplifying
people I disagree with or no in fact
that that is not everybody who opposes
these things there are very distinct
different approaches to the objectors to
many emerging technologies some are very
careful to be talking about downstream
consequences and their lack of
confidence in institutions or human
nature to avoid the extreme unwanted
application of these things for others
it really is a religious view about the
role of humans visa via deity and where
we should stop having control period but
yes there's another group for whom it's
unfamiliar it seems to have a lot of
power and I've heard that it might be
exploited in ways that are unpleasant
right so I've heard that you know I've
heard that your coffee may cause cancer
right right so we've heard the hazard
but they haven't actually taken in the
information about the risk factor right
and and in general it's unfamiliar and
unfamiliar often leads to what one very
prominent bioethicists coming from a
fairly conservative end of the field
called the wisdom of repugnance so they
were trying to elevate this visceral
reaction into a principled approach that
if people share you know widespread
shared repugnance of something it's
telling us something deep even if we
can't quite articulate it it's not crazy
actually it's not crazy at all but it
can also send us off in terrible
directions because it was the repugnance
with intermarriage between people of
for traces that led to the
anti-miscegenation law was the
repugnance of people who are darker that
led white people to enslave dark people
there are many examples in which this
repugnance has been really catastrophic
ly damaging to say nothing of what it
did for generations and generations of
people who are homosexual in their
orientation and transgender people now
and transgender people now which is a
good example of something which is
unfamiliar and I think you're right
other people say it's icky
my only concern is I really want us to
get a different pronoun I don't want to
use the word today I really don't I
don't know I'm a I'm just my seventh
grade English teacher it's still within
me it's a plural it is not great English
you should read Shakespeare and Jane
Austen the pronoun all the time uh yeah
but I forgive them because I love their
writing but but you're right that there
is this kind of big factor actually I
coined the phrase yuck factor same thing
yep I think that that is one that is
manageable because with familiarity
people who are in the yuck factor camp
now begin to split into supporters or
opponents with a more carefully
thought-out basis for the opposition it
might be religious it might be
consequentialist I think that it's gonna
lead to something bad but the the kind
of undifferentiated yuck is now being
differentiated into reasoned
conversation right so that that makes
perfect sense to sort of it's not that
well we think it's yucky therefore it's
probably wrong but we think it's ducky
therefore let's think about it right
let's think why exactly do we think is
yeah is it coming from some principled
moral stance or is it just our reptilian
brain has never seen this before
exactly and so things like test-tube
babies or artificial insemination those
are like hot topics of debate a few
years ago and now I don't think that
there's that much debate left we're kind
of on board with that right we are in
fact in vitro fertilization which you
referred to as test-tube babies I'll
resist that just because continues to
give this image of babies in test tubes
feels like in vitro fertilization has
now become something that is
so familiar because so many people have
used it that it actually began to
impinge on the abortion debate you know
originally IVF was controversial not
only because it was unnatural but
because for the very first time in human
history the human embryo was outside the
human body and was subject to
manipulation it raised again this power
the power to discard the power to
manipulate the power to experiment on
all kinds of things we never had to ask
ourselves before are we allowed to do
that should we do that and those were
influenced in large part also by the
abortion debates but now we've had state
after state that has tried to pass
what's called a personhood amendment for
people who oppose abortion rights there
have been an effort to pass either a
constitutional or legislative provision
that says from the first moment of
fertilization this entity has the same
legal status as a live born baby which
would have incredible number of
implications for how embryo has to be
managed and protected and guarded and
those person who felt personally the
amendments have failed every single time
even in highly conservative states with
a majority of the population opposed to
most abortions why because it would have
the effect of basically criminalizing in
vitro fertilization and there are just
too many grandmother's who wouldn't be
grandmothers if their daughters hadn't
had a chance to use my grandmother's
arguing against you you're not going to
win but isn't it also true that OVA get
fertilized all the time but don't get
implanted and sure and so that now every
woman is a murderer right well intent is
an important concept both in morality
and in law okay right so I think that I
think that that observation is really
important for those who pin everything
on the moral status intrinsically due to
its own biology of the fertilized egg
with the early embryo to observe that in
fact a vast majority of times an egg
will be fertilized but it's fertilized
at the wrong time of the month
and so the uterine wall is not ready to
capture it and it passes out of our body
we don't even realize that we had a
fertilized egg within us because it's an
ordinary menses cycle
and that even for those that take there
are a regrettably high number of
miscarriages whose causes by the way are
largely unknown because of the
restrictions we've placed on ourselves
we can't do research because it's icky
because of the restrictions on doing
research among other things with human
embryos and a more advanced stage so if
your whole point is that it's about the
but biology is what yields moral
significance then the fact that most
fertilized eggs you know have this high
risk of not ever becoming a developed
fetus or baby seems relevant but I think
that even though we talk about abortion
in terms of the sanctity of the fetus
and the right to life of the fetus that
buried within it is actually an entirely
different thing which is all about
intent because the woman who loses the
fertilized egg through no action of her
own is innocent right but the woman who
makes the decision to do exactly the
same thing which is lose that fertilized
egg is now evil Jezebel because she
intentionally swart it to this ongoing
process which might or might not result
in a human and it's that intent that I
think is really important here even
people who oppose abortion rights
generally often make exceptions for rape
or incest because those are presumed to
be in voluntary experiences for the
woman or the girl in the case of incest
so in those cases she's innocent right
and therefore the abortion is okay even
though the the same thing a the fetus
ought to be exactly the same you went
all the way then in within the within
the movement of people who opposed legal
abortion rights there is a kind of split
there is a fracture at that point
between those for whom it really is
about the sanctity of the biological
life and where biology determines your
philosophical status and those for whom
it really is not about the fetus they
think it is but it's actually about
their evaluation of this woman who went
ahead and had sex but doesn't want to
accept the risk of pregnancy as a
fill-in-the-blank a punishment a
deterrent or as her natural fate as a
you as a woman in terms of the way they
think about men and women
yeah I mean I think that religious
traditions often fall into this trap but
even just people more generally like to
judge other people as being bad and
passed laws not letting them do it right
it's very very human kind of thing
something we need to watch out for in
this sphere there is a phrase that you
hear tossed around all the time there
aren't to be a law right I don't like it
it's really difficult in public
conversation it's even difficult in my
classroom with law students to make
people step back and say okay is it
possible I think this is wrong but I
don't think that it should be the
business of the government to determine
whether you can do it it should be
social pressure it should be religious
teachings it should be the you know
advice of your parents regardless of
religion and both liberals and
conservatives sometimes are more willing
than they should be to pass laws that
help their own personal this is
absolutely true it is so you're
absolutely right about it being so
instinctive that if we think something
is just terribly wrong
that we want some power to stop it and
the government and laws and the
enforcement power of the government seem
like a great way to do that it's
certainly more direct but in fact there
is a world of difference between the
things that are right and wrong and the
things that should be legal and illegal
there we make laws about things that are
not wrong they're actually fine but they
have consequences that we can't accept
you know the knowledge that I have about
a particular stock because I'm a stock
because I'm on the board of directors
might make it possible for me to buy and
sell and make money now making money is
not wrong and using information is
exactly what we celebrate except it's an
unfair advantage and it undermines the
integrity of the market and the
confidence of the non insiders and so we
say that's illegal it's called insider
trading now the law does not necessarily
correspond point-by-point with anybody's
morality and nor should it right so I
had a podcast conversation a couple
episodes ago with Carl Zimmer the
science writer and we got into the crazy
world of gene editing and CRISPR in the
future of designer babies so I'm sure I
mean I think it's pretty obvious that
there are bio ethical and
legal concerns coming up here what are
the issues that you worry about the most
in this frontier well let's first make
some distinctions in the application
areas because they raise very different
concerns for those that are unfamiliar
with these things this is another form
of genetic engineering so it's a
continuation of something we've been
doing for a while but it is much more
precise much more efficient and
interestingly can be done by people with
less training in facilities that are
less sophisticated so the way YouTube
decentralized moviemaking
and really transformed a lot of things
this decentralized is a key area of
science in a very interesting way the
democratization of our knowledge about
our own genes and the democratization of
what we can do with them right instead
of having to go to a trained physician
who has a sophisticated lab so once
again we're talking about power and this
gives more power to more people to do
more things with more power to predict
whether it will work right okay so let's
talk about two very distinct areas of
application one is what you'd call
somatic and the other is germline so
germline means eggs and sperm and
embryos where if you make a change it's
not only going to affect the person who
comes from that embryo or those eggs and
sperm but their own eggs and sperm will
have been affected so the grandchildren
great-grandchildren all the way down the
line will also be affected until that
particular trait mutates the way things
do in one jar called germ line because
the germ cells are the gametes are the
eggs binding of germs is you know
causing diseases yeah but think about
germination in the world of plants right
good thank you that helps me connect the
truth there and so that's that's one
area of application that's the far more
controversial one the less controversial
one is what we call somatic it's where
you change cells any kind of cell except
the egg sperm and embryo so if you
change some of the cells let's say in my
liver I will feel the effects but my
children will not okay because it
doesn't affect my eggs that is what we
call somatic editing and so the
advantage there is it only affects the
person who's being treated so now we
restrict ourselves we're only going to
talk about people who are competent and
adult or if it's a child somebody for
whom we're doing this for their own
welfare like preventing recurring a
disease so most people are going to be
on board with that most people are
absolutely be on board with that and in
fact they already are because we're
already doing gene therapy to try and
deal with cancer and blindness but we
have been largely unsuccessful because
it's just such an arduous process and
this may be the ticket to making it a
less arduous process the one area of
controversy that does develop even in
somatic editing is in changes that don't
cure or prevent a disease but alter an
already existing trait that we would
deem healthy and within the normal range
of human capacity so take somebody who's
muscle strength is average and if you
could edit so that their muscles now
became unusually strong that raises
controversies because of the perception
that somehow this creates an unfair
advantage and of course we do that all
the time through other mechanisms yeah
right whether it's nutrition or it's
training so it gets into another entire
debate about meritocracy and earning
things versus having them given to you
and fate because some people are simply
born lucky to have stronger muscles
right yeah so why are they more
deserving than somebody who uses editing
to get to the same point where someone
who are in wealthier can afford a jet to
get where they want to go so that is the
so-called enhancement debate right and
in in many ways it's more about this
concern about society and equity than it
is about the actual phenomenon of the
transformation up to the point where
you're talking about a transformation
that takes you beyond known human
capacities a transformation that gave
you something profoundly different
allowed you to see into the infrared or
the ultraviolet which normal human
beings can't do that raises different
questions about whether or not we want
the power to actually fundamentally
alter the parameters of what we call
Homo Sapien so do we
that's a very long conversation let me
at least address germline first okay the
conversation around germline circles
back again
to this issue of human reproduction
because it is raising fears about
designer babies this again is
biologically untenable it's very hard to
control traits there are very very few
things that are going to be controlled
by a single trait things are most
generous
yeah there multigenic so it's many genes
and the genes are operating against a
particular context and background and
furthermore we are hardly ever
discussing something called epigenetics
which is what affects how strongly the
genes operate right it's like you and I
could play the same keys on the piano
but I'm using the pedals differently it
sounds very different the epi genes the
epigenetics is the pedals and now we're
beginning to learn more and more about
the effect of the microbiome this
incredible number of critters that live
inside of us that also determine how our
genes express so biologically we can't
design our kids we really can't so
shouldn't we as philosophers and
bioethicists still ask the question I
mean it seems like a technology question
whether or not we can or can't and I'm
kind of agnostic I don't really know but
maybe we're wrong maybe we can maybe you
know 50 years from now we figured out
how to make everyone look like Brad Pitt
and Angelina Jolie and is it bad if
people want to do that is there is our
principle is that just a yuck based
stance well it's hard to answer
something that seems so patently
impossible with an answer that is sober
and so I will tell you first that I'd
rather look like Beyonce I'm outdated in
my references you really are that said
we make choices all the time to try to
influence the probabilities there is
something called a sort of mating right
we tend to marry or otherwise have you
know children with people from a limited
range and so that changes the
probabilities that our children are
going to be taller short fat or skinny
brown haired or blond because of this a
sort of mating right and it happens for
all kinds of reasons I mean if even
within a religious group right in my
neighborhood which was mostly
as I said this this mix of people but in
my little part of the neighborhood that
was Eastern European Jewish the men were
short they were just short
my father was 5 foot 3 and if I married
within my group my kids we're gonna be
short you know and so that's in a sense
designing right if I were or I could
choose to deliberately try to find a
guy's tall because I wanted my children
to be taller you know we do this all the
time so part of it is my resistance the
idea there's something fundamentally
alien about trying to change the
probabilities of the outcomes good with
genetics it's all about probabilities
anyway part of my concern here is that I
do think that there are many people
whose concerns are just very much
consequentialist that is we think that
we're likely to make a mistake and the
kids gonna be hurt by it that's a risk
assessment problem that we face all the
time and I completely am on board with
that we shouldn't be doing this until we
have an incredibly high degree of
confidence that the outcome is going to
be to the benefit of the child and any
subsequent descendants which is why
germline editing to prevent a
devastating often lethal disease seems
to me to be a far easier case to make
sure it expands the child's capacities
in a way that guarantees the open future
right that philosophers like Joel
Feinberg have talked about it's a kind
of moral obligation preventing a disease
that one's a closer call I still think
very easy to justify and every time we
take a vaccine we are enhancing
ourselves because we're enhancing our
resistance to disease so this is a form
of enhancement I think makes sense right
again with attention to whether or not
there's an unexpected consequence by
protecting us against this disease do we
suddenly make ourselves vulnerable to a
different one that's a very tricky
problem with multi-generational effects
because you really need to have a
multi-generational experiment to see how
it plays out and that alone may make it
impossible to satisfy these conditions
for making it an ethically defensible
thing to do others I think though have
it have an objection that I think goes
more deeply to the notion that we
shouldn't tinker with the human species
and here I get concerned that
people have an outdated notion of what
it means to say something is a species
okay I think that there is unfortunately
in high school education still this way
of teaching biology and evolutionary
theory as if it's all vertical genes are
only transmitted vertically and that
they go from the past to the future
through the parents to the child to the
child and that the species is a closed
universe of genetic traits when in fact
evolution is not a tree with branches
and twigs ever separating further out
it's this chaotic mishmash of things
that are constantly crossing back and
forth we have genes within us that come
from wildly different species that we've
incorporated into our very cells right
so there's a horizontal movement of
genes that blurs the notion of species
line and so I think that there is an
overly romanticized notion of what it
means to be a homo sapien that leads
people to then give concern that we are
somehow undermining the integrity of the
concept of Homo Sapien I don't think you
can because I don't think that concept
is as pure as people imagined yeah I
think that philosophically that's
exactly right if it we shouldn't we
should know better by now than to treat
things like species or even individuals
as you know out there in the universe
inviolable categories that we can't
break down you know they're things that
are invented they're concepts that are
constructed by human beings to help us
understand the world a little bit better
and as technology evolves then naturally
we're going to hit the boundaries of
where those ideas become useful I I
personally think I set this to Carl also
I personally think that fretting about
where gene editing is gonna go in terms
of human enhancement is kind of a waste
of time because I think it's gonna
happen I think that I don't know how
well it will happen I don't know
you know how effective it will be
because like you say there's a huge
amount of non-linearity and things we
don't understand but I think the people
who try I think the people gonna try to
you know have babies that are ten feet
tall so they can be basketball players
you know maybe so but I think that it's
far more likely people are gonna try to
enhance themselves in ways because it's
much more direct
if what you want is to be 10 feet tall
but actually take a live born child and
inject that child with something to try
to make the child grow taller which
parents do by the way now when they give
their kids human growth hormone even
though the kids are not Ewing growth
hormone deficient if kids are simply at
the far lower end of the growth curve
and the parents recognize that socially
particularly for boys because of the
nature of our society that can be very
disadvantageous in the marriage market
even in the employment market so much
more efficient if you want to make your
kid have a different capacity do it when
the kid's been born doing it at the
embryonic stage is like taking a pellet
gun and shooting it out into a parkland
hoping that something lands in the right
place and that it doesn't have all these
untoward effects because of other places
that had an effect once the kid is born
or once you do it to yourself when
you're an adult you can be far more
targeted and far more confident you'll
get what you want ok that's good to keep
in mind as we go as we go forward what
about we always think about starting
with human beings and making them better
make them smarter and faster and
stronger so what about starting with
animals and making them smarter do we
need as bioethicists to worry about who
counts as a human being what if we take
a chimpanzee and make him really smart
or a dolphin you don't even have to make
them you don't even have to change any
of their current capacities to face that
problem yeah in fact there's us in law
there's something called habeas corpus
motion it's a it's a motion to the court
to force those who have somebody in
custody to show why they're entitled to
have somebody in custody okay and that
habeas corpus motion has now been
brought in several different courts on
behalf of chimpanzees that have been
owned and kept you know kept in
captivity by zoos by circuses and other
kinds of displayers
and so far they have lost in the in the
courts but the argument that they're
making is that even without any change
chimpanzees have an intellectual and
emotional life that is complex enough
that they're capable of suffering right
and that once you're capable of
suffering you have a right not to be
forced to suffer they may not have a
right to go to college because they
couldn't actually benefit from it right
or to vote or in other words it's an
idea that rights
are corresponding to those things where
the rights could actually be experienced
and give value that's why in fact we
already acknowledge this I am NOT
allowed under the law by the way to
torture my cat because she and suffer I
am however allowed to bring her to the
veterinarian even when she is young and
have her put down so to speak which is
killed right right why because of our
belief that the cat can experience
suffering but has a very limited
understanding of future and so there's
not necessarily a right to continue your
own existence but there is right not to
be miserable in it and so you don't even
have to enhance in order to get to this
argument about whether or not animals
should be treated differently do
chimpanzees have a notion of the future
well I think it's a little unclear i am
i think the only law professor in
america who's ever been on a tour of
chimpanzee research stations and has
been sprayed head to toe with chimpanzee
urine all right
this is a unique but it was in the
context of the NIH the National
Institutes of Health deciding what they
wanted to do about the use of
chimpanzees and medical experiments
whether it should continue with NIH
funding and what kind of conditions
should they be held in if they were
going to be used and the family units
are very real the emotional context is
very real but the inability to
communicate makes it terribly difficult
to assess notions of their their
consciousness and their notion of future
Futurity and i leave it to the
psychologists who come up with some very
clever experiments to test whether
animals have a sense of self for example
to try and help us figure that out now
could we edit animals to make them more
useful to us regardless of whether it
makes them more human sure the same way
we breed animals brought a time to be
more useful to us and we've bred all
kinds of farm analyst to be more useful
and we've bred pets to be prettier even
though in fact some of those breeding
methods have led to high degree of
genetic misfortune let's just say
and terrible yeah you know like the hip
dysplasia that you see in some breeds of
dogs which is a direct consequence of
the inbreeding that's done to make the
dogs look a certain way so again the
question with editing is if we can do it
that way why can't we do it this way
that's the why not or since it's
terrible that we're doing that maybe we
should forbid this as a starting point
to forbid the other ways we're already
doing it
those are two good arguments to be
having yeah and a lot of it again
depends on whether or not what you do is
going to enhance the welfare of the
subject of your experimentation when you
use an animal or a human being we are
animals by the way too but when you use
a human animal just for your own
purposes like enslavement we've come to
recognize that is a wrong that's
Immanuel Kant's notion of not turning
people into simple instruments of your
own needs and desires that they are an
end in of in and of themselves and if we
were to think about animals that way too
it would put a natural limit on how much
we manipulate them well certainly sounds
like as a professional lawyer and
bioethicists you're not going to run out
of things to do any just keep doing what
they do I think we're gonna do our best
so Alta Cheryl thank you so much for
being on the podcast
you're very welcome is a pleasure
[Music]